مرحبًا يا رفاق ، تشادويك ، الموز هو فاكهتي
المفضلة في الواقع ، أنا أتناول واحدة كل
يوم ، لكن اليوم سنذهب إلى
الموز في المطبخ ،
وسأوضح لكم كيفية تحويله إلى حلوى
قابلة للكسر بمجرد استخدام
الفريزر ، تعال معي في المطبخ
سأريكم كيف يتم صنعها
[موسيقى
] أسمي هذه الوصفة الرقائق هي الموز ،
إنها قصتي الصغيرة لجوين ستيفاني ، ماذا
يمكنني أن أقول إنني أحبها.
باستخدام الجذع
الذي تذهب إليه من الأسفل إلى الأسفل ،
يمكنك أن ترى أنه يتقشر بسهولة أكبر
الآن سأقطع موزي على
القطر
حوالي ربع بوصة
وسأضعهم في خبز مبطن بالرق  صفيحة
لتحويلها إلى رقائق من أجل حلوياتنا الحلوة ،
لذا فإن الحلويات في هذه الحلويات بسيطة جدًا حقًا ،
لديّ شوكولاتة مخففة لقد صُوبت للتو
في وعاء زجاجي فوق قدر من
الماء ولدي هذا الفول السوداني  دهن الزبدة ، ما
عليك سوى إضافة زبدة الفول السوداني الكريمية
في بعض الحلويات ، السكر ويقلب
في القليل من العسل للحصول على حلاوة إضافية ،
وهذا يساعد في جعله
لطيفًا وسلسًا ويخلطه معًا
تمامًا مثل هذا ، وعندما تنتهي من ذلك ، يمكنك
تناول القليل من
هذه الرقائق ، وهو أمر سهل للغاية.
تحتاج إلى ملعقة مطبخ ، ما عليك
سوى تناول الشوكولاتة
المخفوقة ورشها فوقها حتى يتم تغطيتها بالكامل
مثل هذا ، ثم أود
تقسيم صفيحة نصف شوكولاتة وتناول
زبدة الفول السوداني ثم يأتي الجزء الممتع
الذي نحصل عليه مع كل هؤلاء
وجبات خفيفة رائعة ومجنونة ،
أحب الذهاب للتسوق في ممر الوجبات الخفيفة ،
التقطت بعضًا من
شرائح اللوز وبعض الفستق الأخضر اللامع
للحصول على لون من الألوان
، ويا المفضلة الجديدة هذه رق
ئق جوز الهند المحمصة المحلاة فه
جميلة على رقائق الموز هذه ، وهي مز
ج المفضل لدي رغم ذل
أسمي القرد المكتنزة ،
وأضيف ببساطة
قطعًا من الشوكولاتة إلى زبدة الفول
السوداني ثم أنهيها بقليل من
الملح الرقيق
الآن سأضعها في
الفريزر لمدة ساعتين  ثم
سنأكل الحلويات
[الموسيقى]
لذا جمدت دفعة مزدوجة الليلة الماضية
وحان الوقت للبحث في
رقائق الموز بالتأكيد عندما يكون
ستيفاني
سعيدًا حقًا وسأراك في
المرة القادمة هنا
لمزيد من النصائح حول الوصفات وحيل المطبخ ،
انتقل إلى موقع chadwickboydlifestyle.com